joe biden bien décidé à changer la donne
le président élu américain souhaite
engager rapidement de nouvelles
négociations avec l'iran mais uniquement
après le retour des etats-unis dans
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien qui
l'ont quitté avec donald trump en
consultation avec nos alliés et
partenaires nous allons gagner des
négociations et des accords de suivi
pour resserrer et allonger les
contraintes nucléaire de l'iran ainsi
que pour aborder le programme de
missiles
les etats-unis ont toujours la
possibilité d'annuler les sanctions si
nécessaire éliront le sait joe biden
confirme qu'il fera donc l'exact opposé
de donald trump sur le dossier du
nucléaire iranien
le contexte est tendu il y a deux ans
après le retrait des états unis de
l'accord conclu en 2015 avec téhéran et
la position de sanctions économiques par
le président sortant
l'iran a répliqué en s'affranchissant de
ses obligations notamment sur la
limitation d'uranium enrichi aujourd'hui
nous sommes plus puissant et plus
compétent que jamais en termes d'énergie
nucléaire
nous sommes dans les meilleures
conditions en termes d'installation le
projet de loi ne devrait pas nous amener
à violer la moralité ou à violer les
faits à cause de bataille politique ou
électoral je pense qu'il est d'ailleurs
trop tôt pour évoquer les élections de
il faut parler aux gens des faits très
clairement avec des statistiques
de son côté l'union européenne prépare
une réunion des ministres des pays
signataires de l'accord avant noël
l'objectif éviter que l'iran ne devienne
une puissance nucléaire